j'ai fait un pilote avec jean luc
delarue s'était l'émission scrupules
sais pas si vous vous souvenez sinistre
qui a duré très longtemps et elle est
levée on était trois à passer le pilote
y'avait laurence ferrari il y avait
carole rousseau et moi c'est carole qui
l'a qu'il avait obtenu cette émission et
et moi j'ai vu un type absolument
incroyable c'est à dire que quand on a
fait une première réunion il n'était pas
dans un très bon jour et le jour même du
pilote il n'était pas extra il avait ses
lunettes des lunettes noires parce que
la nuit avait été compliqué et on est je
sentais tout le monde savait ce qui ce
qu'il traversait et pourtant on commence
à faire le pilote il fallait descendre
un grand escalier et je descend
l'escalier et je l'entends lui en régie
dire non on descend pas comme ça et il
arrive et tout le monde pense parce
qu'il n'est pas vraiment il est vraiment
pas bien à ce moment là on pense qu'il
va y chancelant qui va pas pouvoir le
faire et il il prend le micro et me dit
regarde et en deux secondes il est passé
en animateur et j'ai pris une leçon
c'était extra de plus de 100 des plus
jamais de ce que les gens vivent
maintenant je vais rejoindre un truc de
dingue non mais c'était vraiment ça m'a
bluffé parce que il était capable de
faire on off c'est à dire que tout d'un
coup il y avait le type qui donne dans
sa vie privée n'était pas formidable à
ce moment là et puis tout d'un coup
l'animal de télévision à tout ça et on
aimait vraiment en une fraction de
seconde et il m'a donné une leçon de
télé et j'ai trouvé cette dualité
complètement bouleversante ça
s'apparente à descendre les escaliers
aujourd'hui il ya des choses dans ce jeu
sous le casque la binette réinventant
les les les téléspectateurs temps
revenir devant les caméras c'était un
truc a bien changé ce que tu descends
puis d'un moment tu te casses la binette
corner c'est vrai oui non la notoriété
l'argent le succès lui ont clairement
fait péter les plombs et parfois il
devenait très violent il ya une anecdote
de christophe qu'on n'a pas gardé
montage je crois qu'il a failli se
battre une fois avec lui je crois qu'il
voulait vraiment on a laissé vrai que
cette histoire je m'en rappelle ouais
c'est quoi l'histoire en fait c'est on
est en train de renégocier le contrat
evelyne thomas ce qu il était producteur
des vignes thomas cojean morzine ci est
en fait il vient la maison et pour voilà
négocier ensemble le contrat et puis
d'un coup je sais pas pourquoi le ton
monte et jean-luc métier coûte on va
faire un truc on va aller dans son
jardin il a enlevé ses lunettes c'est à
dire à se battre
mais pourquoi je sais comme ça et je
suis dit non mais attends calme-toi et
tout et puis d'un coup il dit d'abord
avère donc
jeudi un verre d'eau jus d'orange et
vous dire un truc un peu plus fort je
ramène une bouteille et puis on commence
à discuter à négocier tout ça et puis un
moment dis moi ça me va pas dit on sort
on se bat ça a duré gaza pendant 20
minutes mais j'adore barca
c'est donc ça m'a pas dans son rôle